good morning everybody thank you for
joining my name is Kevin Albee I am
assistant associate director of clinical
microbiology at the University of North
Carolina Medical Center an assistant
professor of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine at the University of North
Carolina School of Medicine and today I
will be talking about meningitis and
encephalitis some overview some
epidemiology and what our current
diagnostic methods are
the objectives for today's talk are to
describe the difference between
meningitis and encephalitis and the
challenges with diagnosis to describe
the most common causes of meningitis
encephalitis and to describe the
diagnostic tools used to diagnose these
two diseases
meningitis is estimates for bacterial
meningitis or that there's somewhere
between around 4,000 cases annually and
5,000 deaths in the u.s. deleting causes
of bacterial meningitis in the United
States our structure caucus pneumonia
Group B streptococcus I Neisseria
meningitidis Hamas influenza and
Listeria monocytogenes viral meningitis
or aseptic meningitis is also very
common however the exact frequency is
very difficult to calculate due to
insufficient diagnostic testing and this
is something that will come up several
times throughout this presentation and
including in a few slides
like most diseases there are a number of
national organizations devoted to
increasing awareness of meningitis and
encephalitis this particular poster is
taken from the National meningitis
Association which gives just some of the
classic signs associated with bacterial
meningitis and things to look for
encephalitis similar to meningitis a
large number of cases do not have an
etiologic agent and bacterial viral
fungal and parasitic causes have all
been documented there are also a number
of non-infectious causes for
encephalitis that have been described
and one of the main differences in
between distinguishing between
meningitis and encephalitis are some of
the altered Mental Status abnormalities
that you get with people who have
encephalitis things like memory problems
loss of taste and smell personality
changes these are all evident some or
all of these made in patients who have
encephalitis
to distinguish between meningitis and
encephalitis there's a few basic
definitions which are again one way to
differentiate between these two diseases
so from a strict definition standpoint
meningitis refers to an inflammation of
the meninges and these are the membranes
that surround the brain and spinal cord
the classic symptoms associated with man
Jettas are a very significant headache
often described as the worst they've
ever had
and then trouble or pain when moving the
neck so though this is a stiff neck
you know that is again the clot one of
the classic signs of meningitis
encephalitis refers to inflammation of
the brain itself and so as I was saying
before the the hallmark attribute for
encephalitis would be altered Mental
Status somebody the water even further
there are other diseases which are
associated with inflammation within the
central nervous system and these include
myelitis encephalomyelitis
meningoencephalitis which as the name
might suggest as a combination of both
meningitis and encephalitis and let them
leptin meningitis
so how does want to go about evaluating
a disease such as encephalitis if you
look at the IDSA guidelines there's a
very large table part of which is
displayed on this slide here and you can
see if you zoom in and enlarge the font
you can hopefully see that there are you
know a number of tests depending on what
etiologic agent you think may be causing
the disease and so this is not meant to
be an exhaustive slide showing all the
different ways but just again an
overview of the complexity that may be
involved in testing for these patients
so they talked about a few slides ago if
we think look at the u.s. for the
epidemiology of meningitis encephalitis
you can see that we have a wide variety
of causes and so if you look at you know
approximately 20,000 a little over
20,000 cases over a three-year period
you know you do have a number of viral
positive so enterovirus was was positive
in a number of cases you have a large
number of bacterial again that 3600 so
around that 4,000 cases of bacterial
meningitis but you have a large number
of unknown etiology so in this case you
know about 5,000 were unknown and that's
actually really good
for looking at the the kind of incidents
in actually finding a causative agent
you'll see from what kind of some
additional slides that the unknown
etiology is it tends to be a lot larger
in terms of percentage and we'll come
back to this slide and what it means
that if we find something how that can
affect the duration of antibiotics and
antimicrobial therapy
looking at a long trend over a bacterial
meningitis by different organisms in the
United States again the most common ones
being streptococcus pneumoniae a
Neisseria meningitidis tomasulo's
influenza but you can see what's the
impact of the pneumococcal vaccine and
the meningococcal vaccine have had so if
you look at the introduction of the
pneumococcal vaccine around the year
2000 you can see that you know
pneumococcal meningitis was you know
maybe starting to head down trend a
little bit but you saw this distinct
downtrend and pneumococcal meningitis
after the implementation of vaccine and
sustained drop in incidence similar with
meningococcal meningitis to the point
where actually mini Takako meningitis
has dropped below kind of general
gram-negative meningitis and
staphylococcal meningitis
over the past couple of years so it's
actually left a less common cause why is
that important because the change in
epidemiology again changes how we think
about what we should do for diagnostic
modalities
where you acquire the disease has a
significant impact on what type of
organisms is causing the disease we know
this for a lot of infectious diseases
and the same is true for meningitis and
encephalitis so in this particular
figure we're looking at community onset
meningitis by analyzing 600 patients in
a Houston hospital over a 6-year payant
span they looked at both you know they
defined the patient's whether they were
acute or subacute based on how long they
had their symptoms and they looked at
where they found the organisms so you
know what I was alluding to earlier
about how frequently the ideology is
unknown here's a much more common figure
so at the top line you can see that our
unknown percentages around 70 percent
for the acute patients at about 65
percent for the sub acute patients so
again a vast majority of cases do not
have a defined etiologic agent for
community onset meningitis bacteria were
relatively common so about 10 percent of
cases with things like streptococcus
species which would include
streptococcus pneumoniae being the most
prevalent so this kind of fits with what
we have seen a smattering of other
bacterial species you can see viral
ideologies down there with HSV making up
the majority of kind of those viral
cases what you'll see as we go through
is that there's a few different viruses
that switch in terms of their
ideological prevalence but HSV and
enterovirus tend to be up near the top
while other viruses such as West Nile
st. Louis virus and things like that
tend to be a little bit lower depending
on the patient's underlying conditions
some of the fungal ideologies such as
Cryptococcus and Histoplasma then become
you know potentially more relevant and
more prevalent
this is in contrast to health
care-associated neuro invasive
infections and this is really focusing
more on the bacterial causes but what
you'll see is that you have a large
number of gram positive organisms that
are not streptococcus I so it you know
the previous slide against the vast
majority of the bacterial isolates were
streptococcus pneumoniae you had one mr
essay you know so no collecting of staff
so these agents do not cause
community-acquired meningitis however
they are very highly associated with
health care-associated near invasive
infections and adults and so something
that we need to consider is again what
is our patient's background what is
their history in terms of healthcare
exposures in terms of trying to think of
what organisms should we be looking for
and how should we be looking for them
in terms of aseptic meningitis for
children and adults you can see here
because we don't have a good idea of
what else could be causing a meningitis
so we have a negative bacterial culture
we need to do some other testing it's a
kind of a mixed bag in terms of what
people end up doing you can see HSV PCR
herpes simplex virus PCR being performed
quite frequently tends to be positive
more frequently in adults as far as
looking at meningitis encephalitis so
you may see that skew a little bit more
chill towards children you can see
enterovirus being more prevalent in
children than in adults with kind of a
rare other virus here or there but again
if you look at the bottom line you look
at the unknown etiology and you see 86%
in adults
61% in children have an unknown etiology
so to kind of focus in on that kind of
finding of enterovirus and parvovirus
and children this is a study that looked
at 285 children with suspected enteral
viral infection and they looked at what
are the best ways to diagnose and our
overall meningitis so if you look at the
figure on the top right you can see for
enterovirus the sensitivity of you know
real-time PCR was about eighty-five
percent with perfect specificity and a
high negative predictive value viral
culture was very poor at about 28% parka
virus had a similar result for CSS PCR
and owing to the difficulty in isolating
and identifying parco virus and culture
you can see that there was actually no
positives detective via viral culture
in patients who have meningitis you can
actually find the virus and a lot of
other sample types but again the the
unique thing here is that PCR is clearly
a superior source it's clearly a
superior test in terms of in terms of
sensitivity the specificity can
sometimes be hard to determine because
what is turns what is your gold standard
what is your true positive and so what
does it mean if you find positives in
patients who have meningitis with no
cause or no identifiable cause that you
find enterovirus and the stool or in or
in the urine like what how do we
interpret those that's some of the
diagnostic delimit clearly they have a
lot of the virus present
could it be associated with their
symptoms it's hard to definitively tell
arboviruses are frequently something
that we think about every summer they
tend to make that you know tend to make
the news and are a very important cause
of meningitis in the United States
meningitis encephalitis in the United
States so this particular slide looks at
the incidence of various neuro invasive
disease classifications of arboviruses
far and away West Nile is the most
prevalent and most common arbo viral
infection in the United States a
smattering of other viruses do crop up
from time to time throughout the country
lacrosse virus Powassan virus Jamestown
Canyon virus st. Louis encephalitis
virus eastern equine encephalitis virus
and in this particular one there was
some unspecified California serogroup
viruses they asn't flow every year
though in terms of kind of the overall
prevalence where they're being found in
things like that so you know if people
have been listening to the news this
year eastern equine encephalitis virus
has been popping up a lot more this
particular year in the US and it has in
others we can see that from kind of West
Nile over the past few years and look at
comparison of 2014 to 2018 in terms of
the incidence of West Nile virus you can
see that you know in 2018 head was our
highest year in terms of knittin neuro
invasive cases also our highest year in
terms of non neurones of cases but a
relatively normal year in terms of
viremic blood donors so again it's kind
of some interesting data looking at kind
of the prevalence of this disease and
how ABS and flows over time and so you
can see you know 2015 was another
relatively high year in terms of
mortality from West Nile virus but 2016
wasn't as bad by some of the metrics
there are always other things to
consider so I haven't talked a lot about
fungi you know so things like
Histoplasma other bacteria
you know Mycobacterium tuberculosis you
know especially in other parts of the
world is a huge cause of meningitis but
something may be not as prevalent to the
US audience you know if we have
indwelling devices or specific zoonotic
exposures again other bacteria arise to
the list we've all you know are all
familiar with fungi that pop up kind of
via astral genic outbreaks
you know fungi are in our environment
and can things light and can occur
cause causing meningitis and
encephalitis and then we have other
things to consider like this molecule
here which is our NMDA receptor and so a
recent study out of Landsat Neurology
really kind of was quite interesting in
looking at autoimmune encephalitis
but was actually associated with prior
edge HSV encephalitis and so this is
kind of really you know perked up a lot
of people's thoughts about okay so now
not only do it to worry about the
instruction the kind of immediate
infectious cause but what are some
potential complications of the
infectious encephalitis and so this is a
Spanish cohort there's a couple of
different cohorts one was looking at 50
patients who had HSV encephalitis over a
four-year period these patients
developed had encephalitis and then
ended up developing a secondary
autoimmune encephalitis if they looked
for antibodies to those in to those
immune markers you're finding NMDA
receptor antibodies in two-thirds of
cases
there was another cohort of patients who
looked at patients who you know so the
first cohort patients got better and
then developed a secondary encephalitis
these second cohort were patients who
you know were adequately treated but
kept on getting force and 90% of those
patients of those 50 patients who had
continuing worsening of symptoms even
after the diagnosis with HST
encephalitis even though they were on
therapy 90% of them had antibodies to
some neuronal surface antigen against 75
percent of which were NMDA and so this
is really going to start turning you
know kind of turning things on their
head and thinking about the whole
process you know it used to be okay we
have our diagnosis work done now wait to
think of okay what are the implications
of the diagnosis that we get
so how do we get to that diagnosis the
detection of bacterial meningitis and
encephalitis is still pretty
straightforward and still done largely
the way it has been for the last 50
years there are some improvements in
technology that we'll talk about but for
the most part it's about concentrating
your sample putting it onto solid media
performing a Gram stain ideally with
Saito centrifugation to concentrate the
organism on the slide for for viewing
and letting the the culture grow however
can we improve our art our job can we do
a better job of detecting bacterial
meningitis and encephalitis if you
remember to some of the figures at the
beginning of this slide again maybe 15%
of cases maybe you know that's on a good
day are we getting positive actionable
bacterial meningitis encephalitis
results now some of that's just because
it's not causing the disease and some of
it is because of poor methods so this
study looked at about 1300 samples that
were inoculated into both on toast agar
plates as is kind of traditionally done
into blood culture bottles so this is
something that's commonly done in the
microbiology lab in terms of other
sterile fluids joint fluids pleural
fluids things like that where there's
fluid that's inoculated onto a solid
auger but also into blood culture
bottles to enhance detection they had 70
pot samples which were positive only via
the bottle so you know if you look at
the chart at the top you had 74 which
were detected by both the agriculture
and the blood culture you had seven
which were detected by only by the
agriculture and seventy again which were
detected only via the bottle and chart
review considered 30 of them to be
either definitive or probable infections
and includes things that you know again
are pretty pretty hard and fast you
would consider a true infection things
like Canada and our bacteria saying
staph aureus things which if we think
from an organism sample
are definitely you know known causes of
meningitis there was another study that
looked at a different bottle
manufacturer with similar findings
the other question is can we do
identification faster so molecular
message is one way to do identification
faster but it's not the only way and so
this particular study looked at could we
actually use multi talk mass
spectrometry on positive spinal fluid
that was posited by Gram stain so the
idea being that if there's enough
organism to make a Gram stain positive
you might be able to actually do multi
toss directly on the sample and get a
positive result it you know with a small
study looking at 44 samples what you see
is that gram-negative rods it actually
wasn't too bad you know 17 out of 21
gram negative rods were correct
there was one incorrect identification
and three new identifications for other
grandma grand stain reactions other
organism groups Grande positive cocci
yeasts it just was not a great test
there wasn't necessarily a lot of useful
information coming out of it you know in
the case of Grand positive cocci one out
of twenty was correct but two out of
twenty were incorrect so you actually
were more likely to get an incorrect
result than a correct result so it's a
you know an interesting publication it
shows some potential but clearly it's
not the it's not the answer
fungal meningitis we have a number of
diagnostic modalities beyond culture to
look for fungal meningitis we can do
staining techniques such as India ink
though that is rarely done in labs in
the United States anymore very commonly
performed or antigen based tests such as
the cryptococcal lateral flow or latex
agglutination tests and then we can
actually use biomarkers such as baited
1-3 glucan and to see if there is other
fungi present all right so one of those
markers which again is a very good
biomarker would be baited 1-3 glucan and
in this case you know we're talking
about the Xterra hilum infection the
zero hilum outbreak from a number of
years ago which was associated with
patients who received contaminated
steroid injections these were
contaminated at the point of point of
manufacture with ixiaro hilum mold well
you can see from this chart is that
patients who were culture or PCR
positive but almost uniformly had beta 1
3 glue cans greater than 230 pica grams
per mil on the other side your control
subjects again very rarely did they have
high positive beta 1 3 markers if you
look at the actual breakdown of patients
again who had meningitis with this with
this infection a large percentage of
them had high level beta 1 1 3 beta D
glucan markers and so it's just showing
how patients and how these other kind of
markers could be used in a case where it
might be otherwise difficult to make a
diagnosis
viral meningitis and encephalitis is
another area where the diagnosis is
quite difficult and so this is looking
at a three year period in China looking
in children for the diagnosis of viral
and meningitis and encephalitis what you
can see is that they had a large number
of viruses that were implicated in
meningitis and encephalitis but they
also had to do a number of different
tests so if you look down the bottom the
piece dated a PCR test for enterovirus
ha's they had a multiplex test for
herpes viruses which included HSV vzv
BBC MV and hhv-6 they did IgM testing
for in the CSF for Japanese encephalitis
virus they had serum IgM tests for other
things such as tick-borne encephalitis
virus dengue mumps and rubella
you know not only shows the diversity in
terms of viruses which can cause
meningitis and encephalitis but also how
the difficult it can be to make that
diagnosis
talk a little bit more about molecular
diagnostics for meningitis and
encephalitis there's really three
different bins that we can think about
we can think about the targeted PCRs so
there's FDA cleared tests for for HSV
bzv and enterovirus there are lab
developed protocols for pretty much any
other pathogen that you can think of you
can think of multiplex panels for which
there are both CEA and FDA marked
options and then what's kind of emerging
and now coming to market in terms of lab
developed testing is next-generation
sequencing or meta genomic analysis
so to focus on the panels there are as I
said there are two panels one is C II
marked for from fast-track Diagnostics
which has a variety of different kits
one looking at viral meningitis agents
one looking at agents that cause
bacterial meningitis one associated with
new NATO meningitis and their so-called
neuro nine panel which is kind of a
specialty panel for for viral causes of
meningitis you in this particular study
was an evaluation of about 480 CSF
samples with the bacterial and neuro
nine panels a 21% positivity a large
number of enterovirus and AB no virus in
this particular cohort and a large
number of streptococcus pneumoniae one
of the things which you will know is a
general concern when looking at
molecular targets for bacterial
pathogens you can see that only 7 of 14
streptococcus pneumoniae and one of 8
Neisseria meningitidis were covered in
culture so part of this might be the
Festivus nosov the organisms and the
difficulty in recovering the culture in
general presence of prior antibiotics
can also play a role in low rates of
recovery but the other concern is always
the potential for false positives
in the u.s. many people are familiar
with the film array meningitis and
encephalitis panel the Emmy panel which
was FDA cleared in 2015 for the
detection of 14 targets directly from
CSF which was obtained by lumbar
puncture you can see the targets present
on this panel ecoli Hamas influenza
streptococcus pneumoniae Listeria
monocytogenes streptococcus agalactiae
necessary meningitidis the viruses
herpes simplex virus 1 & 2 enterovirus
humans herpes virus six varicella-zoster
virus human porreco virus inside a
megalo virus and in your fungal target
Cryptococcus neoformans in body i when
we look at the performances of the
meningitis encephalitis panel it was
really quite good in the multicenter
evaluation but there were some things
that were very interesting to note one
of which was again Owens did to the
difficulty of making a diagnosis of
meningitis or encephalitis and that
there were a number of times in which
the Emmy panel had a result which was
different from the comparator test so
the culture or be it PCR there was a
difference between what the Emmy panel
said and what the what the kind of
standard of care testing had had
described and that after doing some type
of description analysis where did those
fall out what was interesting is that if
you look at the table here on the right
kind of the vast majority of issues are
quote-unquote false positives meaning
things that were detected by the film
array that were not detected by this by
the kind of the routine testing or the
comparator testing so there were 43
cases are four to three times worse the
philaret panel picked up something that
the kind of routine testing did not
there are only six instances where the
routine testing picked up something that
was not picked up by film array what you
can see in terms of the results is that
in terms of the ones that were missed by
film array initially kind of arbitration
and discrepant investigation most
those were truly false negatives and
that you know something limitation to be
to bear in mind for for that testing
when it came to the positive so the
extra detection is by the panel I what
you can start to see is that it's really
much more difficult to sort out there
were definitely cases where what was
picked up by the panel was a benefit to
you know to the would have been a
benefit to the patient things that were
not originally described as being in the
samples that were arbitrated to be kind
of the true result was the presence of
that analyte however equally as often
that analyte was deemed to be a false
positive so it can be difficult to
determine how do we actually go about
evaluating the significance of some of
these positives results when an extra
detection could equally be a false
positive as it could be a true positive
what we know is that from archive
samples again for the vast majority of
targets the film or a performs extremely
well there are some targets that we need
to keep an eye on so things like HSV and
Cryptococcus neoformans in Cryptococcus
ngati i and for which i'm going to go
through a few cases which have kind of
Illustrated some of the concerns and
some of the limitations of panel testing
with this with kind of a broad use
approach so you know in 2018 chew it all
describe two cases of Cryptococcus
neoformans that were negative by the
emmy panel but positive by cryptococcal
antigen and culture in one instance the
patient was actually sent home and had
to return upon growth of the buzz the
bug the other case the physician taking
care of the patient actually requested
additional testing and which one of
which was ripped across small antigen
which was positive and so there really
was no change in the management of that
patient
I in 2017 there was a report of a
positive hhv-6 and a kidney transplant
patient you know importantly in this
case you can see you know where the
overall utilization of this test falls
into it so the there was a panel test
sent there was a bacterial culture sent
but there were no fungal or AFB studies
once the patient deteriorated then they
started doing additional testing
including additional studies for fungal
and AFB and now that included for
cryptococcal antigen and that's when the
patient started to improve once they're
placed on appropriate therapy for
Cryptococcus so just because the targets
are present on the panel you know again
it's important to realize limitations of
any approach and that these these tests
are not in some instances these tests
are not a replaced for the current
methodologies in use
one of the probably more famous cases
was where a positive hsv-1 on an enemy
panel kind of delayed the diagnosis of
Mycobacterium tuberculosis so a test and
organism that's not even included on the
panel would not you know readily be
available and could not necessarily even
be suspected but you know testing was
delayed because of the positive result
initially
if we think about all of these cases the
initial testing significantly altered to
patient management so that in some
respects that's good what we want is we
want to be doing diagnostic tests that
are causing action in the clinicians
otherwise why are we going to the effort
of performing those tests and a lot of
these cases there was continued decline
as a patients and they were transferred
to different institution or had
different providers evaluate their care
ultimately it was skepticism of panel
based results that led to additional
testing via other modalities or
searching for additional pathogens
so it really begs the question you know
for some of these what does it positive
to mean and so if we think about things
like common viruses something like hhv-6
what does the positive detection of HH
basics really mean and i think the
answer is we don't really know so in the
skin this study from a number of years
ago so you know 2001 a number of years
ago it looks at the present presence at
hhv-6 in Normal and neoplastic brain
tissue so thinking something that has
nothing to do with infectious
encephalitis infectious meningitis but
just looking for the presence of the
virus and what we can see is in that
about a third of cases either being
metastatic or not metastatic neoplastic
brain tissue or in normal brain tissue
we're finding presence of hhv-6 DNA and
so this really you know again begs the
question of what is the significance of
a positive result for this particular
virus this extends to other herpes
viruses so in this particular study
they're looking at patients who had who
were classified as having either
tick-borne encephalitis or enteral viral
meningitis and you can see that even in
those cases again you find a smattering
of herpes viruses popping up hsv-1 hsv-2
bzv hhv-6 sometimes even multiple
viruses at HSV 6 and vzv so what does
this all mean I don't think we quite
know yet so in some cases is it possible
that these patients have infections with
multiple viruses or they're reactivating
some other herpes viruses and it
actually is a benefit for them Tracy
something like a cycle appear it
certainly may but it really just
emphasizes the fact that we're very
early in understanding the kind of the
diagnostic implications of testing this
group because for so many years it was
so difficult to identify an etiology for
these diseases
the one approach which has really
started to pan out is looking at what's
your pretest probability so in this
particular study out of Lancet
Infectious Disease from a couple of
years ago it looked at the probability
of diagnosing meningitis and
encephalitis and a patient who had a low
white blood cell count in their CSF so
in this study they had 457 patients who
had a low white blood cell count in
their CSF only three had positive
results
one was a Cryptococcus neoformans in a
patient who had an H a who was HIV
positive and in two other cases the
immune status is unknown so these could
have also been in you know compromised
patients for which we expect doing some
type of selective testing may not be a
benefit
the idea of selective testing and the
value of selective testing goes back a
little bit further to this study out of
Wash U from 2015 that looked at kind of
the overall prevalence of viruses in
their institution so on
in total they looked between 2008 and
2012 and they found somewhere between
one and two percent of their virus
testing in the CSF was positive so it
did you know and this is the sort of
thing that we see across the board is
that the diagnosis of viral encephalitis
is a rare event and so they looked at
what were some of the parameters that
may help predict the positivity of these
patients and you've got a kind of a
smattering of results so for the CSF
protein you can see that in HSV and vvv
the CSF protein was more likely to be
elevated than in the in the positive
patients than in the negative patients
but that didn't really hold true for CMV
or EBV if you looked at glucose you may
see a decrease in glucose for HSV but
you're not really going to see a change
for some for the other viruses
if we look at the cell counts for ripe
red blood cells again HSV there was kind
of a trend towards more a white red
blood cells being present for HSV
positive cases in HSV negative cases
same thing with vzv but again not nearly
not super solid in terms of okay we can
really hang our hat on this parameter of
some way to read this out if you look at
the presence of white blood cells
however that's where you start to see a
more profound impact in terms of or more
profound difference in terms of the
difference between what you've seen
positive versus negative cases so you
know an HSV you can see the you can have
the vast majority of patients who were
HIV positive at a high nucleated count
and those who were negative had a very
low nucleated count in their CSF and
that actually held true for all the
different viruses that they were looking
at so HSV bzv CMD + enterovirus
other thing that they looked at was the
time of year matter so we know that
especially for something like
enterovirus there is a season to
enterovirus typically peaking in the
u.s. in the kind of somewhere between
July and September timeframe late summer
early fall and you can see here that is
indeed where they saw the peak of their
enteral viral activity was in the summer
time frame and so if they implemented
selective testing you know there is a
unique criteria and so this group set
criteria at greater than ten white blood
cells for an immuno competent patient
understanding that if the patient were
immuno compromised it may be hard to
mount the response that you could
actually see in the CSF in terms of like
a white blood cell count
they also limited enterovirus testing to
seasonal testing so they only tested
during April to October for enterovirus
and what they found is that they saved
about $60,000 annually looking by doing
this selective testing and not only did
they end up saving money there were
actually fewer requests in general and
so you can see that just looking at the
numbers requested just having some type
of conversation about the potential
value of testing and something having
some type of diagnostic stewardship or
algorithm in place reduced by you know
somewhere between eight and twenty
percent the number of tests even
requested so it really shows that you
know the step of sewage stewardship has
impact it has value and one kind of last
caution for widespread testing and so
this is a study that was done in a
tertiary care hospital it was a ten
month study where they essentially
allowed widespread testing of meningitis
and encephalitis pay panels during that
time fear period you know this is one of
the concerns seventy persone lee 70
percent had a clinical suspicion for for
CNS infections so in 30% of cases there
was actually not a high clinical level
of clinical suspicion
that could be ascertained from the chart
for an infection
you know the yes that patient had up to
a CNS process but you know they were net
there is not a suspicion for infection
which kind of follows if you look at the
number that were receiving impaired into
microbials for infection kind of again
only sixty percent were receiving
impaired into microbials friskiness
infection and so really the question at
that point is why are you doing the test
if you do not have the pretest
probability no matter what the test is
should you be performing that test in an
absence of a suspicion of infection very
low numbers tested positive so six point
four percent or forty five patients and
of those positives nearly a quarter were
determined by blind to be blinded review
to be clinically insignificant so again
the caution of widespread unchecked
testing of any type especially for a
disease state or disease states which
are poorly understood could really lead
to some problems
that being said it it is it is a
diagnosis that is fraught with
complications so I just presented data
about how you should use play of cytosis
in the CSF to help limit testing that
goes out the window when you're dealing
with children so the idea that that CSF
CLIA cytosis is predictive of infection
is not true when you look at patients
who are less than 12 months of age so in
this study you know there were a number
of patients you know who were less than
12 months of age who had positive PCR
results without any evidence of plio
psychosis and so it's important to know
that that epidemiology changes and so if
you look at for example the cell count
performance down there at the bottom in
the infant cohort the negative
predictive value of the cell count was
71% so again a very poor test to look at
cell count as your as your main
predictor 8/4 for a PCR positive result
um this is another study showing the
same thing looking at again please
cytosis in positive results and children
in this particular study they use white
blood cell count of nine as their
definition employer cytosis and again
although you have a number of normal
negatives with cytosis you do have both
bacterial and viral positive cases that
had normal cell count by the definition
of less than nine cells per ml and so
again it is something that is needs to
be aware of and that again children and
adults don't always follow kind of the
same pattern
one swing thing that is quite clear
however is that the impact and value of
rapid testing so regardless of whether
you're testing one one target or 20
targets the ability to do testing faster
has a positive impact on patients and so
this is a retrospective study looking at
at Children's Hospital in LA looking at
360 cases of negative HSV testing so
again here we're just talking about
negative results not much not even a
positive results but if you have a test
with good negative predictive value you
can do things like deescalate
antibiotics or discontinued antibiotics
such as acyclovir so in kind of the pre
period were batched LTL DT HSV testing
was performed and took a median of
almost 24 hours you were if they were
able to reduce that to you know nine
hours once they had some sample to
answer HSV testing solutions in place so
not only did they reduce the time for
test result they also reduced the time
in acyclovir usage and so in children
and in adults being able to reduce the
amount of antimicrobial exposure is
really one of the kind of hallmarks of
active stewardship and ways to help
improve patient care
we know that that's you know having a
diagnosis helps and so this is the same
figure that I showed at the very
beginning of the presentation looking at
kind of the breakdown of different
causes of and meningitis and
encephalitis but also what the identity
or what the impact of having a diagnosis
was on antibiotic antiviral or
antifungal therapy so you can see that
not only like to trip the in the
Children's la study could a negative
result be helpful but a positive result
can also be helpful so if you look at
that the idea that someone who has an
unknown etiology for meningitis or
encephalitis is going to get five days
of antibacterial therapy whereas if they
have a positive enterovirus they may
only get three days of antibacterial
therapy that's a significant improvement
again reducing that antibacterial
exposure reducing that some of that
selective pressure the likelihood of
developing other infections just C
difficile again we can also talk about
the benefits of reduced antimicrobial
therapy you know we know some of the
issues with antifungal therapy and some
of the toxicity is associated antifungal
antiviral therapy again being able to
reduce that burden by having some type
of positive result impacting that those
days of therapy is very valuable
but ultimately the current diagnostic
tests are insufficient and so again this
is showing another figure that I had at
the beginning of this study where we
pointed out and at the bottom depending
on what you're looking for depending on
what your math trick is you know
somewhere between 60 and 80% of cases of
meningitis and encephalitis hair are
unknown we do not know what that
etiology is so we can't refine testing
we can't different we can't simplify
antimicrobial therapy and we and we
really need to figure out what's what to
do and that's and that's where next
generation sequencing comes in and so
I'm only going to have one slide on
next-generation sequencing and it's
really just to demonstrate some of the
power the power of metagenomic
sequencing from a number of cases that
have come out of the chu lab looking at
identification of unknown organisms or
you know not thought of organisms by
using meta genomic next-generation
sequencing in patients who have
meningitis or encephalitis you know this
is an excellent tool but you know what's
the ability to do this on large scale is
still somewhat unknown and you know
these are the positive cases are the
ones that are going to headlines you
know there's still a large number of
these cases that are negative just
because there's the presence of this
test doesn't mean that it too does not
have all the answers it too suffers from
some of the issues of other testing
methodologies where if the virus or
pathogen isn't present it can't detect
it you know and that sometimes you do
need multiple different modalities you
do need serologic testing to diagnose
arboviruses things like that and so it's
a great start and I think a great you
know the diagnosis of amenitized and
encephalitis is a great place to really
look at this this testing and kind of
refine this testing but it is certainly
not going to be the answer or the only
test that that we need for this disease
so in conclusion hopefully i've
established for you that the diagnosis
of meningitis and encephalitis is a
complex and multifactorial process that
there is really no one best test yet
that improvements can still be made for
all of our diagnostic modalities but in
that most importantly it's a great area
for diagnostic stewardship so so for
very few disease states are there kind
of such profound studies showing the
impact of potential diagnostic
stewardship in terms of escalation of
antibiotics the escalation of
antibiotics the ability to use other
less expensive and quicker laboratory
tests to determine what to do and the
impact of you know pretest probability
in terms of the ability to act on
positive or negative results
like to thank you very much if there are
questions there are two email questions
to the to the program and I will
certainly answer those that I can or
point you in the right direction so
thank you very much and have a wonderful
rest of your day